illegal immigration in the u.s. is often
talked about in the abstract
it's about policy borders and laws but
what is it like for the roughly 30,000
immigrants who are held in detention
centers around the country on any given
day not good little to no legal
representation lack of medical services
sexual abuse malnutrition and solitary
confinement those are just some of the
issues plaguing these usually privately
run detention facilities the most
vulnerable of the detained are women and
children in 2014 60,000 families mostly
from Central America cross the us-mexico
border in search of safety and better
lives so what happens to families who
are detained by Border Patrol
they're sent to family detention centers
where immigrant women and children are
held for months at a time
they're never charged with a crime nor
granted any legal rights and they face
bonds as high as $15,000 the two main
family detention centers are in Texas
and can hold up to 3,000 women and
children at a time hundreds have already
been deported though forced back into
situations that caused them to leave in
the first place
situations like rampant drug and gang
violence in El Salvador Honduras and
Guatemala
I spoke via Skype with yanita in January
she fled Guatemala with her three
children because gangs have threatened
her family
yanita and her children were held in a
small cell with another family for over
two months before being released while
they wait for their deportation hearing
she says they were made to feel like
criminals and that's kind of the point
Secretary of Homeland Security jeh
Johnson says the center's are supposed
to send a message that if you come into
the US illegally quote we will send you
back but Mohamed Abdullahi erases who
works with these families says the
family detention centers send a
different message what the US government
essentially is doing with the running of
these family detention centers is
preventing refugees from being able to
see safety which is the responsibility
of every country to provide refugees
with protections immigrant human rights
groups are petitioning for families like
you need us to receive political asylum
they've also supported hunger strikes
led by detained women protesting unsafe
conditions in the facilities ultimately
they want the family detention centers
phased out and for these immigrants to
live with relatives while they await
deportation hearings but fixing the root
causes of illegal immigration to the US
well you'll have to watch other aj+
videos for all that